in my life to give another example
the mongers would have twice the assets
they now had if i hadn't made one
mistake of omission back in the 1970s
and
really stupid
and
i got i blew
an opportunity would have doubled my
present net worth
that is a normal life you get one or two
how things work out
it's the basis
we all know people are outmarried but i
mean their spouses are so much better i
think what a good decision that was for
them
and what a lucky decision way more
important than money
and
a lot of them did it when they were
young just they stumbled into it
now
you don't have to stumble into it you
can be very careful
a lot of people are wearing
signs
danger danger do not touch
and people just charge right ahead
that's a mistake
well you can laugh but
it's still a horrible mistake
and
it's been fun for the people on this
board to know one another and
work on these oddball things and to
handle life's vicissitudes
of course it's very peculiar that we're
so old
i mean imagine a place where gary wilcox
is one of the young men
and
his wife is still a golf champion but
that's not because she's good when she's
old
i mean
yeah
it's
it's an amazing group and that's an
interesting example too
imagine being as old and as impaired as
i am
and having a pretty good time
how does that happen
well you
that is another story a couple of other
stories too because you like stories
here's an apocryphal story that is very
instructive
a young man comes to visit mozart
and he says mozart he says i want to
write symphonies
and mozart says how old are you man
psalm 23.
mozart says you're too young to write
symphonies
and he says but mozart he says you were
writing symphonies when you were 10
years old
mozart says yes but i wasn't asking
other people how to do it
now there's another mozart story
here's the greatest musical talent
maybe that ever lived
and what was his life like well he was
bitterly unhappy and he died young
that's the life of mozart
what the hell did mozart do to screw it
up to make himself oh he did two things
that are guaranteed to create a lot of
misery
he overspent his income
scrupulously
that's number one that is really stupid
and the other thing was he was full of
jealousies and resentments
if you'll spend or spend your income and
be full of jealousy and resentments you
can have a lousy unhappy life and die
young all you've got to do is learn from
mozart
you can also learn from
that young man who was asking mozart how
to write somebody
the truth of the matter is that
not everybody can learn everything
some people are way to hell better
and of course no matter how hard you try
they're always some guy that achieves
more
some guy or gal
and
my answer is so
what do it does any of us need to be the
very top of the whole world it's
ridiculous
and
another thing that people do like bear
guard is amazing is they build these
enormous mausoleums
i think they figure they want people to
walk by that mausoleum and say gosh i
wish i were in there
anyway
you can see we've had some fun as we go
along
and it's worked so well
but if you actually figure out
how many decisions were made in the
history of the daily journal corporation
or the history of
berkshire hathaway it wasn't very many
per year
that were meaningful
it's a game of being there all the time
and recognizing the rare opportunity
when it comes and recognizing that the
normal human allotment is to
not have very many
now it's a very competent bunch of
people who sell securities who act as
though they've got an endless of
wonderful opportunities
those people are the equivalent of the
racetrack tout
they're not even respectable
it's not a good way to live your life to
pretend to know a lot of stuff you don't
know and pretend to furnish you
a lot of opportunities you're not
furnishing
and
my advice to you is avoid those people
but not if you're running a stock
brokerage firm you need them
but it's not the right way to rank make
money
and
this business of
controlling the costs and living simply
and
that was the secret how much my
warren and i had tiny little bits of
money
we always understood our incomes and we
invested and
well you know if you live long enough
you end up rich
it's not very complicated
and
and
now there is a part of life
which is
how do you scramble out of your mistakes
without them busting too much
and we've done some of that too
and
if you look at berkshire hathaway think
of its founding businesses a doom
department store a doom new england
textile company a doom trading stamp
company
out of that came berkshire hathaway
now we
handled those losing hands pretty well
when we bought into them very cheaply
but of course the success came from
changing our ways
and getting into the better businesses
and
it isn't that we were so good at doing
things that were difficult we were good
at avoiding things that were difficult
finding things that are easy
by the way when we bought the daily
journal that was easy what we're doing
now
in this software business is difficult
but due to the accident of these good
associations and the fact that these old
colleagues have lived so long
we're doing pretty well in the new
business
it has potential
and it's fun to do
and
and uh
how many declining newspapers have
hundreds of millions of marketable
securities lying around and
a new business with some promise
we're like the last of the mohigans
oh
he's giving it to somebody important
well i'll take some questions
[Music]
you